hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar exosomes from pure isolation to
standardized analysis by flow cytometry
i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
and brought to you by multne biotech for
more information about our sponsor
please visit miltonbiowtech.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits
joining me now i would like to welcome
our speakers adriana pasquale a product
manager for molecular analysis at milton
biotech and laura mueller product
manager for flow cytometry regions at
milton biotech and joining them for the
q a portion of this webinar will be
stephen weil a group leader at art
indeed and milton biotech welcome to you
all you may now begin your presentation
welcome everybody to today's webinar on
exosome research solutions my name is
ariana pascual and i'm the global
product manager for molecular analysis
at maintenance biotech we also have here
my colleague clara miller which is a
global product manager for flow
cytometry and stefan build group leader
in the research and development
department which will join us during the
q a session
okay so let's get started with the
webinar
this is today's agenda first i will give
you your introduction about
extracellular vesicles or eb's
research and applications then i will
introduce the different eb isolation
methods with a focus on immunomagnetic
isolation after this my colleague lara
will give an overview on eb analysis
specifically on our multiplex flow
cytometry assay then she will show you
data obtained with using our essays
followed by a short summary and the q a
session
okay so let's jump into the topic
extracellular vesicles short ebs are
membrane surrounded particles secreted
by every cell type since the first
observations in 1983 the interest in the
research of extracellular vesicles have
been continuously increasing as shown in
the chart illustrating the number of
publications per year
in 2012 the international society of
extracellular vesicles was found in
order to advance and also to guide the
research on these vesicles and since
then the interest has been extended from
fundamental fundamental research to
translational and also to clinical
applications just as an illustrating
example up to today there have been more
than 190 clinical trials involving eb's
many of them also investigating the use
of extracellular vesicles to treat copic
19.
okay so what are exactly ebs and why are
they so interesting ebs are as i
mentioned before membrane-surrendered
vesicles that are secreted
to the extracellular space from every
cell type they can be classified into
exosomes and microvesicles based on
their biogenesis so while exosomes are
generated by fusion of multivesicular
bodies with a plasma membrane
microbesicles but from the plasma
membrane
and the size of these bicycles barriers
between 30 nanometers and one micrometer
being
exosomes usually smaller than
microbasicos
it has been shown that ebs are involved
in self-cell communications and they
carry diverse biomolecules including rna
dnas proteins and lipids and they carry
these molecules from the parental cell
to the recipient cell
and the surface and also the cargo
of the ebs will not only depend on the
cell type but also on the cellular
metabolic status and on the
physiological conditions for instance
the composition of it be secreted from a
cell with a healthy state with the fear
from the one secreted during cancer for
example or during a different
physiological condition like exercise
as shown in the illustration
tetraspanins are these transmembrane
proteins uh broadly found at the surface
of ebs and are commonly used to identify
it and also to separate ibs from complex
samples
however so far there is no unique marker
that allows to distinguish between the
different types of eb's and this is
admire harder in the field since as
mentioned before micro bicycles and
exosomes are very different and the
biogenesis in they are different the
biogenesis pro process they are also
different in the composition and may
have also different signaling functions
here we will talk a little bit about the
different sources and current
applications of ebs as they are secreted
to the extracellular space as i
mentioned before ebs are present in all
body fluids including saliva urine or
breast milk additionally they can also
be generated in vitro and collected from
the cell culture supernatant of culture
cells
due to their non-invasive and easy
accessibility and their different
composition different profiles that
mirror the physiological conditions of
the parent cell
eb's have
gained a lot of attention in different
applications for instance they have been
shown to be very useful approach to
investigate disease biomarkers
specifically cancer biomarkers and they
are also being investigated as
delivery entities in drug discovery but
also in vaccine development among other
very interesting applications
after the overview about eb research and
application i will focus on the
different technologies and must use
methods for the isolation of ebs
as mentioned earlier ebs are easily
accessible in body fluids like urine
saliva or plasma
most of these sources where we can find
these vesicles are highly complex and
they are highly heterogeneous and
contain not only bees but many other
vesicle cells
particles and proteins and a proper
isolation will allow us to separate
clean and also concentrate the eps from
all other components of the sample and
this is a crucial
step for many downstream applications in
order to generate reliable results
one of the requisites is purity
isolation methods need to assure a high
purity and a specificity and this is
particularly challenging when considered
that eps are highly heterogeneous in
size and composition
so in this table we find the most common
use methods for exosome isolation or eb
isolation one of the most used methods
is ultracentrifugation
these methods allow eb isolation from
big volumes and although it can be
potentially or it can lead potentially
to high yields it is very time consuming
and one that cannot be sure of the
specificity of the isolated fraction
since all the other components with the
same density will be also
isolated like ultra centrifugation other
physical methods have the same
disadvantages and can potentially
co-purify non-eb components
mentally biology has the balance and
athlete based on immunomagnetic
isolation and this assay targets
specific ep membrane markers which allow
for a higher specific and high purity
exosome isolation one of the big
advantages of immunomagnetic isolation
is also that it allows for the
separation of a specific episode
population
based on different surface
markers
okay so how does this method work so
this assay is based on positive magnetic
isolation and use magnetic microbeads
coupled with specific antibodies
anti-cd9 c63 and cd81 that recognize and
also they bind to the specific tetra
spannings
on the eb membranes here you can see the
principle of the assay and what happens
is that first the sample containing
database
is incubated with the magnetic or the
immunomagnetic microbits within the
sample ebs will be labeled with the
microbeads containing or coupled to the
antibody and then the sample is then
loaded onto a separation column placed
on a magnetic separator the magnetically
labeled ebs will be retained within the
column where the unlabeled vesicles and
other cell components other contaminants
and proteins will run through the column
so in the last step the pure eb sample
is included from the column by removing
the column from the magnetic field so as
you can see it's a
very smart principle and a very easy
protocol to follow
so here i listed some of the features
and advantages of the exosome isolation
kits the kids use immunomagnetic
microbeads in the nanometer range and
this nanometer or nano size microbeads
are always a state so they always stay
in suspension creating an even
distribution of the antibody which
allows for a much more efficient eb
capture than other magnetic microwaves
that tend to precipitate
the assay is fast and it's very easy
doesn't require
special equipment it can be used for
virtually any eb source including serum
saliva plasma
urine and
from both human and mouse another
characteristic of this assay is that it
allows sample volumes as little as 0.5
milliliters which i think it's very
interesting when you only come with very
limited material which is what usually
happens when working with
for instance liquid biopsies from
patient samples
additionally this technique has been
proved to give excellent results in
terms of purity since it efficiently
removes contaminants and isolates
functional eps regardless of their size
so here you can see the results of a
study by michael faffel lab comparing
different isolation techniques where
they show that compared to other
isolation methods i mean monomagnetic
isolation exhibits higher purities and
it shows very clear bands in this
protein analysis by cluster blood
for the common eb markers so as i
already mentioned a pure eb sample it is
crucial for obtaining high quality and
trusted results in downstream
applications like for example
flow cytometry protein analysis by flow
cytometry
genomic analysis but also electron
microscopy for example
as mentioned before during the
introduction of this method the other
big advantage of immunomagnetic
isolation compared to the other
isolation method is that this method
allows to perform subtyping so it is
able to separate different ibisa
populations within the same sample and
the physical separation of ebs depending
on their differences in surface
biomarkers and in the profile or surface
proteins this has great potential and is
winning a lot of interest in the film
for instance it is a very interesting
approach to consider in order to develop
new assays to investigate uh for example
cell type a specific ibs or purify ibs
released during a specific pathological
condition
and just to finish with this part i like
to mention that this technique is
compatible with many downstream
applications including
electromicroscopy rna sequencing and
also analysis by flow cytometry which
will be covered by my colleague in the
next section
thank you ariatner so after isolating
high pure evs you can of course perform
exosome sequencing or micro rna
sequencing to investigate the nucleic
acid cargo of your ev sample
but in this section of the webinar i
would like to draw your attention to the
protein cargo and specifically i'm going
to present to you how to use flow
cytometry to screen multiple surface
markers on your ev sample
but before jumping into the topic let's
first have a look at the common methods
used to analyze ev proteins
different methods can be used to analyze
ev proteins as shown here these include
for example western blood mass
spectrometry electron microscopy and
flow cytometry western blood is commonly
used to demonstrate the presence of ev
markers however it requires large sample
volume and is very time consuming then
we also have mass spectrometry which is
more sensitive but requires specialized
setups as well as extensive operator
expertise and also tends to be very
labarious and in both cases it's not
possible to analyze proteins at single
ev level
instead single evs can be analyzed by
electron microscopy where you can
further detect proteins by
immunostaining but here only few evs can
be analyzed and is technically quite
challenging
and another method to analyze single evs
is flow cytometry which can also be used
to analyze the protein carbonyl freebs
flow cytometry is a powerful method
which is widely used in various research
in clinical labs for high throughput
analysis
unlike other methods it enables the
rapid measurement of multiple physical
and biological properties of cells or
particles as they pass in suspension to
one or more laser beams thus properties
like size or immunofluorescence can be
easily measured and quantified
and because of all these advantages flow
cytometry hold great promises for also
being used to analyze evs
next to the flow cytometry itself the
most important component of a flow
cytometry experiment comes down to the
antibodies then by using highly specific
antibodies which are conjugated to
fluorescent markers it is possible to
identify and quantify the target of
interest
recombinantly generated reaffinity
antibodies are designed and optimized
for flow cytometry they provide superior
lactolot consistency and purity due to
standardized production rigorous
purification and stringent quality
controls
all reaffinity antibodies contain a
specifically mutated
humanity1fc region to eliminate
background signals
on top of this they all have the same
itg-1 isotype and thus only require one
universal isotope control
this greatly reduces the complexity of
experimental planning
and all the benefits recombinantly
generated reaffinity antibodies offer
come in handy when analyzing small
particles like evs by flow cytometry
although flow cytometry is widely used
in the field its straightforward
applicability to analyzing evs is very
challenging and this is mainly due to
the small size of abc illustrated here
so you can see the size of an ev is
about 100 times smaller than the size of
a cell
and small particles like evs they hardly
scatter any light
and i've analyzed by flow cytometry you
can see here in the plot on the right
that signals are detected in the side
screen and forward scutter but it's very
likely that these are ev aggregates or
swarms
then single evs they would appear down
here on the left corner marked by the
red circle but this region is so heavily
overlaid by noise and often a trigger is
used to avoid this noise and therefore
the evs are not visualized
still it is possible to analyze surface
markers on avs by flow cytometry but the
core expression of markers on the same
eb is very difficult to address because
again of the small size of the ev is
hard to distinguish single evs from ev
aggregates and on top of this it's
further hampered by the potential
blocking effects of the antibodies
to overcome some of the mentioned
limitations and to simplify the analysis
of ev surface markers by flow cytometry
we developed a multiplex beat based
essay depicted here how does it work
well the essay consists of 39 capture
beads which are labeled with varying
amounts of two dyes to generate 39
distinct bee population which can be
easily distinguished by flow cytometry
these are shown here on the left
and each of these capture bead
population is coupled to an antibody
specifically targeting one of 37
exosomal surface epitopes or to isotope
negative controls
then after the incubation with an ev
containing sample these capture beads
are stained with a detection region for
example a cocktail of apc-conjugated
antibodies against the tetraspan in cd9
cd63 and cd81 which are commonly
expressed on evs
and then consequently sandwiches
complexes are formed between the capture
beat the eeves and the detection reagent
and based on the floor sense properties
of the capture beads and the detection
reagents a semi-quantitative analysis of
ev surface markers can be easily
performed by flow cytometry
and the parallel detection of 37
different surface markers then results
in a characteristic surface profile of
an ev sample
let's have a closer look how this would
actually look on a flow cytometry so as
you can see in the first plot with the
side skid and forward scatter gauge you
can easily exclude the dopplets and
aggregates based on the bead size
then with the pe and fitzy gate as shown
on the second plot you can nicely
discriminate the 39 different bead types
based on the different ratios of pe and
fits the labeling on the capture beads
as i mentioned earlier
with the apc channel you can ultimately
detect the captured exosomes as shown on
the third plot
and as you can notice here a three
dimensional diagram would be required to
show the signal intensity for each b
type separately but in the pe apc
diagram up to 5 b types have the same pe
signal intensity and therefore they
appear overlapping in the diagram
nevertheless with the multiplex
speed-based evsa for force automatically
you can easily detect and semi-quantify
37 markers on your ev sample
the advantage of this unique multiplex
speed platform is therefore that allows
you to profile proteins on evs very fast
and simple by flow cytometry the essay
works on any flow cytometer with a blue
and red laser to detect 5c pe and apc
and it does not demand extensive
operator expertise
as it can be easily implemented into
most laboratories for routine ev
analysis and you also save precious
material by directly screening 37
surface markers simultaneously and a
list of these markers shown here on the
right so these include common ev markers
like the tetra spanish shown here in
orange but also immunology and cancer
epitopes can be analyzed so we also have
here for example cd20 or cd4 which are
general b cell or t cell marker
respectively
as mentioned it's a semi-quantitative
method so the signal intensity detector
with detection antibodies depends on the
ev concentration and the range of
detection was for example assessed here
by using five different doses of evs
isolated from hexals as input and as
expected the signal intensity for
positively stained bee population
decreased with decreasing ev input as
you can see from left to right
however reliable results were obtained
when the supernatant contained about 1
million to 100 million heck-derived evs
and taken together the results show that
the beat based evsa enables a sensitive
semi-quantification of ev surface
markers
s is also customizable and can be
adapted to individual needs
this was shown in the following study
when antibody against fall air 1 was
used as staining reagent
foil air 1 on evs was reported to
shuttle folate into the brain and as
examined as a biomarker for ovarian
cancer
eevees from pre-cleared cell culture
supernatant of a common human ovarian
and the necrozone cell line showed
robust expression of abundant markers
like tetrahedral spanins and epithelial
markers like cd 326 when a detection
reagent cocktail was used as you can see
in the left plot
when the anti-fall i1 apc antibody was
however used as detection antibody also
signals for the cd9 cd63 cd81 and cd 326
capture beat populations were gained
this indicates that the evas expressed
for layer 1 and that those avs also
quick express the tetraspanins and cd326
the data also highlights that custom
detection antibodies are compatible with
the essay and therefore it is easily
possible to assess whether a certain
candidate surface marker that's not
detectable by the kit is actually
present on evs or not
the sa is further flexible so additional
antibodies can be added for
multi-parameter analysis and no
pre-enrichment is necessary to run the
maxplex exosome kit so evs can be
analyzed by flow cytometry directly from
different sample types or after
isolation
this is shown here where the ev surface
signatures of major human body fluids
like plasma 0 and csf were profiled
briefly different ev input amounts of
each sample were analyzed and the
results were then visualized as heat
maps for comparison
and you can see that high and consistent
levels of tetraspannings were detected
in precalculate czech samples but also
in non-chromatography peripheral plasma
as well as in serum with no major
difference among ev surface markup
profiles in the later two samples as you
can see in the left heat map
therefore under standardized condition
the multiplex speed base essay not only
represents a valuable tool to
characterize but also to compare evs
from different sources
after learning more about the basic
principle of the multiplex speed-based
evsc for flow cytometry and its features
and advantages let's have a closer look
at some data
as my colleague highlighted in the
beginning cancer-derived evs have great
potential to be biomarkers for early
clinical diagnosis and evaluation of
cancer therapeutic efficiency
in a study depicted here surface
proteins of evs captured directly from
assets obtained from five overall cancer
patients were analyzed with the beat
based assay
ovarian cancer is among the most common
types of cancer and one of the most
lethal gynecological malignancies
the low survival rate and poor quality
of life of patients with ovarian cancer
is in part due to the lack of early
diagnostic methods and high chemo
resistancy rate thus there is an urgent
need to identify new biomarkers for
early diagnosis and prognosis of ovarian
cancer
and the results of the beat-based essay
show that besides the common exosome
markers like cd9 cd63 and cd81 also
markers were detected indicating blood
cell-derived physicals which include cd4
and cd8 for t cells and also cd14 for
monocytes
interestingly also was the observation
that samples from different patients
showed significant differences in the
levels of key tumor markers such as cd
326 or eprim and cd 133 or prom1
these results clearly indicate the
presence of tumor-derived evs in the
assets of patients with ovarian cancer
and are online with other studies
showing that the formation of malignant
acids is a hallmark of advanced and
metastatic ovarian cancer
other experiments with the multiple flow
essay show that evs isolated from cancer
cell lines can be distinguished by
differing tumor markers
as you can see here mcsp positive evs
were captured from all three melanoma
samples an mcsp is a dominant melanoma
cell surface marker and a
well-established target for melanoma
immunotherapy
in contrast melanova evs hardly showed
any cd 326 or epchem compared to colon
cancer evs as demonstrated by the
binding to their respective capture
beads and highlighted with the arrow in
the graph
thus you basically have two markers
which would allow you to distinguish
between the melanoma and colon
cancer-derived evs
i hope these experiments could give a
glimpse of the potential the multiplex
speed-based evsa holds however many more
studies are published employing the
essay to investigate the biology of evs
and to explore their potential in
clinical applications
and one application i would like to
highlight here at the end is the use of
the essay to characterize and assess the
quality of evs for clinical use
especially mesenchymal stem cell-derived
evs have gained a lot of attention as a
cell-free component to potentially treat
different diseases and conditions like
for example myocardial infarction or
covet-19
however ensuring consistency and good
quality of the ev therapeutics is of
tremendous importance to safely move
forward into the clinics thus assessing
the general repertoire of 37 surface
markers on ev can add an additional
level of information for quality control
to sum it up evs are membrane surrounded
particles that are secreted by virtually
every cell type they function as
intercellular messenger and hold great
promise for diagnostic and therapeutic
applications we here at miltoni offer a
complete workflow for exosome research
from isolation to analysis
the immunomagnetic isolation allows high
purity ev purification and enables high
quality downstream analysis
additionally you can physically separate
different ev separations from a complex
sample
the beat base flow cytometry assay then
enables to screen multiple potential
markers on evs in parallel
and our solutions are widely used by
experts in many research fleets
including immunology cancer neuroscience
stem cell research or for example
infectious disease they can be easily
integrated into any workflow to advance
both basic and clinical eb research
and with this we are already at the end
of the webinar so thank you very much
for your attention and we look forward
to your questions for your attention and
we look forward to your questions
and thank you ariana and laura for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
and it looks we already have
some incredible questions coming in from
our audience members
our first question
what is the size range for the magnetic
isolation beads and the graphics show
them as small compared with evs but is
this really true with respect
and i think that you have muted yourself
i wanna
yes so
indeed the graphics might be a little
bit misleading here so our microbeads
are in the size range of 80 to 120
nanometers so it's pretty much the same
size as the exosomes
the advantage of the smaller size is
that
the beads stay in suspension and
therefore you have a very efficient
binding
of the vesicles to these beads because
they are in close proximity during the
binding reaction
thank you so much and
our next question do you have a release
antibody conjugated with beads for easy
so far
we don't have release antibodies for the
exosomes so this is something we are
working on
so the current setup of the beats
they are not releasable so the basically
stay on the beats
but you can
elude
the
vesicles from the beads
if you lying the beads so for rna
analyzer protein analyzes you can do the
lies on the column then the beets stay
on the column and you lies trust the
protein and rna content of the beads
during the illusion and then go down go
for a downstream analysis
and then you can exclude the beats
thank you so much
now when using flow cytometry to analyze
evs
is it known that the equipment must be
properly rinsed before use and what
cleaning protocol do you use in your
flow cytometers
that's a very good question so i think
this is one of the advantages of using
the by the beads for the analyzer of the
vesicles
so these are large beads about uh four
micrometers in diameter so they can
easily be uh
detected in suicide meter like usual
cells
and we do not
detect single vesicles
by this
essay
so therefore if there would be some
contamination of vesicles in the
solution we simply would not detect them
because we just detect the signals which
are related to the beats and you don't
see the signals from the background so
therefore
we have a rather specific signal
and of course you do the
usual cleaning routines you would do for
a cell analyzer on the flow cytometer so
the same cleaning as you
do in your routine work on the flow
cytometer so there's no cleaning
required because we do not analyze
single evs
thank you so much i want to thank our
audience for these great questions
coming in
what is the size range for the magnetic
isolation beads and the graphic shows
them as small compared to evs is this
really true with respect to excess
so i think i already answered this so
the size range is 80 to 120 nanometers
so it's similar to the exosome size
range so it's a little bit misleading in
the pictures shown in the graph so they
are
more or less as small as the vesicles
thank you very much
do capture beads rely on tetrapan and
expressions only or can they be
customized to use other capture
strategies
i think i can answer this question so
our
isolation microbeads so far we only have
products that rely on the tetraspamming
expressions the
ninety-one c63
um and but
we do not have at the moment other micro
bits for excess some isolation however
we have in the portfolio many other
micro beads that could
potentially be
used for for exosome isolation or at
least tested for other markers
thank you very much and what is the
maximum number of coast breast markers
that can be detected per
so again a very good question so as you
have seen in the presentation um
we are
applying a kind of elisa a principle so
if we have one capture antibody coupled
to the beads and then a second antibody
carrying the label
to
label the bound vesicles so you only get
a signal if both markers are present on
the vesicles so basically we always
detect the presence of two markers on
the same vesicle to get the signal and
of course
as we are using one dye in the standard
assay we always detect two markers on
the same vesicle
however it's of course possible if
you're using flow's hydrometer to use
additional
dies
additional colors is another antibody
and thereby you can get more information
about additional markers but for each
marker you always get the information
of
the two markers present on the same
vehicle so if you
staying with two different antibodies
uh of course you will not know whether
these antibodies stain on the same
vesicle or on different vesicles
because
of course on one
beat
many basically can be bound so therefore
it's in principle possible
that the staining comes from two
different vesicles
giving the same signal giving a signal
on the same bead type so therefore you
always can detect two markers on the
same vesicle
but you can combine this with different
markers of course to get more
information on these vesicles
thank you very much and can you give an
example of an infectious disease
yes um so yeah for i think uh currently
the most prominent one that's being
explored is to treat um covet 19
as an example for infectious disease
um be it being used as a vaccine
delivery system or to even yeah treat it
thank you very much
now what do you think about aldehyde
sulfate latex beads for analysis of
exosomes for flow cytometry
so these beads are a perfect tool
to analyze single markers on the
vesicles so you basically
non-specifically bind the vesicles to
the beads and then this allows you again
to use standard flow cytometry to detect
the markers on the vesicles
however as said the
binding to the beads in this case is a
non-specific binding therefore you of
course
cannot be sure
what you have captured on your beats so
i think having the eliza principle
increase the specificity of the essay
and in addition due to the color coding
of our beads
you can address 37 markers in parallel
and this saves you a lot of time and
also
if you're
talking about
precious
body fluids also material because
basically you're using the same amount
of material and get 37
information information about 37 markers
instead of just one using the classical
non-specific binding for the beats
thank you very much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in our next audience
member says thank you very much for this
formative talk i'd like to know if it is
possible to isolate exosomes
from the superintendent of the
fibroblast civil culture
[Music]
yes and theo you can isolate
exosomes or other evs from cell culture
supernatant of any kind of cell that you
are calculating this includes
fibroblasts
or even
neurons mses
wonderful thank you very much
now is there any em data using capture
beats
yeah there are there are publications
where they um use our exosome isolation
kits and then they proceed to
em analysis
and yeah it is possible to see the
exosomes
and how about do you need to separate
magnet beads from exosomes to use wb
analysis
so it's not required um
you can simply
lyes uh the basically bound to the beads
and then uh perform the gel analysis so
the gel separation and then the western
blot the beads would stay in the
pockets of the gel so they do not
interfere with western blotting
the other possibility is to lie the size
on the column
and then do dilution
within the magnet
then the beats will stay on the magnet
and again then you can run the child for
the western blot and do the analyzer so
there's no interference of the beat this
is downstream analyzes using western
blotting
thank you so much we have time for some
more questions a few more do you have
any microbial um microbial specific
antibody that could be used for
microbial micro vessels vesicles
detection
so unfortunately we don't have these
so
when we talk about the max black speeds
the staining antibodies they are human
specific so therefore we have an
additional essay for mouse
so the antibodies are really species
specific so therefore you would not
detect
any other
vesicles from
like the microbiome so that's
of course on the one hand a positive
effect because
you know that you really have a specific
staining
so for example if you if you're using a
serum in your cell culture it's always
the risk that you get
vesicles from the serum in your samples
and this might interfere with your
analysis
and we could show that due to the
specificity of the antibodies
we do not get any signals from these
bovine evs so it's really specific
but on the other hand if you are
interested
from different species the acid will not
work unfortunately
thank you very much
our next question the ldl share the size
of exosomes do you know if the ldl
express cd9 cd81 or cd6
if this question is affirmative how can
we differentiate this particle
again very good question
so
this
lipids
they do know are not associated with the
teta spinal proteins so therefore they
will not be enriched using our
microbeads so in contrast to physical
isolation methods like like
ultracentrifugation
they always have the risk that some of
these particles have the same density or
size and therefore are precipitating
together with the vesicles using the
surface markers you can really
get rid of these
lipid particles and enrich for vesicles
thank you so much
is it possible to customize the magnetic
beads with streptavidin to capture
biotin antibodies against specific
cell-derived ev markers
so i i can i can um give a little bit of
information here and then maybe stefan
you can um
so um elaborate a little bit on that i
think it is potentially
possible to to customize or to use
streptavidin microbeads to
to capture eb um
ebs
that are labeled with biotin
thank you so much and we have time for
two more questions
can the auto maps of miltoni be used
for
immunomagnetic isolation of exosomes
um i think we will not recommend to use
the auto max for for exosome isolation
since it is um designed for cell
separation but we have the multi-max m96
separator that we could
it could potentially be used for access
on isolation we have validated the
um the isolation with this separator
here in miltoni and it works
fine thank you so much a final question
that we have time for are there any
special requirements on the flow
cytometer to be used for the max pokes
assay
so
there are no special requirements
so most of the fluid cytometers can be
used to analyze the bug specs essay so
you need a blue laser
so 488 nanometers and the red laser 635
nanometers
and then so the ability to detect
the ftc pe and the atc in three
different channels so i think that's
a setup which most of the flow
cytometers can work with so there might
be some exceptions exemptions but most
of the flowcytes can be used and then
you can easily set up the essay on this
flow cytometer
i want to thank all three of you for
your time today would you like to
provide any closing remarks for
noise i am
thank you very much for all these
interesting questions um
yeah and you can find
many more information on our website or
yeah reach out to to to us or to our
military colleagues for more information
thank you again for your
oh go ahead and please go
ahead yeah thank you also from my side
for all the questions it was really
interesting discussion and unfortunately
we could not answer all the questions
but for those questions we couldn't
answer we will come back to you by email
and answer these questions as well
yes exactly so also from my side thanks
a lot for this lovely discussion
i want to thank all three of you again
for your time today and for your
important research and i also want to
thank lab roots and our sponsor miltoni
biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank the audience for joining
us today for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand
we laboratory you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone bye